people who don't know get right with
this produced by blast
and and see look i had that beast since
probably like 2014.
what do you mean you had that beast
since like it was just like he just
emailed he had sent it to me so me and
blas i've been on blast
right yeah so he sent me the beat but i
was only doing trap [ __ ]
okay so you were like this ain't for me
yeah he sent me some trap [ __ ] too so i
hit the trap [ __ ] yeah you feel me
but it wasn't hard like i was doing trap
[ __ ] but it wasn't like
okay this nigga's different he sounded
like everybody else doing trap [ __ ] you
feel me to me that's how i felt
so i came back that's actually the only
song i did in l.a
that and i did uh naked in l.a
so when i got back to la i was doing a
session
oh okay so ray the thing i'm saying to
fc rand j i'm signing fce
and pooh you know pooh jeter on laced
yeah yeah so poo
uh was working with chris o'bannon so i
guess they didn't know we knew each
other
so they had us come to the studio so
we just came to the studio at random and
like they was trying to get us to see if
he was going to vibe
and i'm like bro that's chris like
that's the homie like he already knows
he makes my first ever song right my
very first song ever
so and that's my boy like we been have
songs together and stuff like that when
he was in high school
and all kind of [ __ ] so it was just like
chemistry like we did a couple records
and when we got to he was like you got
some beats because he make beats too so
i was like
oh you don't go to no like no session
with nothing i make beats and ask for it
right right right like i'ma use your
beats but so i was he was like you got
some more beats
i'm like yeah i got some hard [ __ ] like
i played the blast beat and then we was
like yeah we gonna do this one
we just knocked the song down it was
quick like 30 minutes